welcome to this 15 move game playing
magic of 13 from the US while playing as
a rather optimistic yeah he in fact it
does play what could I play being we all
sit down okay let's go d 5 but to try to
play some other lines than I usually do
okay maybe I get should I dare to play
the the tracks LA with Bishop c5 this is
this is really crazy i had i don't know
the line at all it's very risky to play
against the seven and 1700 player Bishop
c5 I really don't know like here one or
two moves after that okay if not he I
mean if it is not working out he has a
nice Sunday check okay this was quick
night f7 now this this i feel like i can
i can somehow play without knowing it
really but the other line I'm not I
wasn't so sure I mean this is also a
dangerous for black but still neither f7
Bishop f2s is completely completely
bonkers what no I cannot believe it
really hmm
so just just d6 song is there c'mon just
t6 intending 94 and not doing anything
fancy you could have already thought
about moves la gana Bishop F to enter
and things
okay one way is just a tree h3 Knight f3
Bishop g4 but the direct Nyjah for also
looks very very tempting there is night
d5 check though you should have to also
possible yeah spoiled for choice really
the Bishop g4 has 95 not really
92 95 cheeky eight but this is also the
night hanging okay I'm doing that not
really calculating this to the end
Jeff yeah at least not a big choice back
to e ad er now g2 is of course under
fire and g5 so i don't really am don't
really see what is playing now kini
eight and some way is a double attack +
f2 is hanging by the rook by the bishop
and by the night okay if i take it with
the night as Queen age five but it's
just check really know that that's the
right move I'm pretty pretty sure Queen
edge five is really just a check and it
detects immediately now that that's fine
Knight takes rook takes this is
completely winning
okay rook jacks and king you 1 I have
queen age from and this is this is
killing I believe threatening Queen
takes you four and threatening the
discoveries yeah no use and pretending
head to to to thank ya this is this is
simply simply decisive ugly another cube
mate sd3 rookie to double check King
takes you to Queen F to checkmate you
can play night XD seven check but this
is really just a spy check I don't this
is really just just one check and that's
it yeah Quinn checks in form simply and
check as h1 and and everything I 93
actually okay but I win the Queen which
is also not particularly particularly
bad can take here now I can take III
first both pretty good okay here this
Queen h5 which is still not not really
meaning much okay I'll just I just
chance come on this is this is the
easiest I can try to meet him actually
queen age too but ok the Queen for
absolutely nothing you should really
take
white will be yours i made soon enough
yeah the trucks law I think it also
called sometimes wilkes-barre variation
something like that it's crazy but it is
it is a valid opening line this is
Bishop c5 in some way it is the most
principled response to 95 simply
ignoring this but the question is what
is why the next best museum the pro knee
yeah and not an expert but I always
thought that that night xf7 I mean it
must be critical in a way and then black
it's a taking here which is really crazy
I think King takes is it's not
particularly good i believe it is chance
that's at least a draw if i'm not
mistaken and and i think even that is
questionable of course it's a completely
crazy position but I think King f1 is
the the critical move and then there
there are lines like that which I cannot
really assess here but I think there is
something like that well I would have
played that just for fun but yeah of the
slave this is like total war no into
idea yeah and there also is of course
you should have set which is the solid
choice in a way now we're treating this
is I think the main the main variation
and now I think rook f8 is normal yeah
but but now and now I'm not sure I mean
I only know this and that like sometimes
plays let's say d6 and get the Queen
over and the very often black has play
with the F file and send that black has
obviously a development of Vantage but
the king only seven is it's also quite
quite strange so you cannot really speak
of a normal conventional position
very M very murky rocky stuff yeah but
he played king f1 which is probably
something like a mouse slip I mean there
is no real rationale behind the move and
now there are many good good
continuations even this I mean I thought
I saw this but I wasn't sure if I really
want to want to play it yes mostly
because something like that is a bit
strange but probably off even this is
scooter so good good for black yeah here
I'm just preparing Knight g4 and yeah
it's also a distinct edge from like
according to the machine yeah this earth
is flat out winning yeah it is totally
winning no no no defense anymore check
you find now we have this this mentioned
double a check on the night and on f2 so
here it's it's a gonna check check yeah
just just taking everything yeah this
line can be a very interesting and
because white players simply will not
know much about this this crazy line
very very unlikely that you meet an
expert because well this is very very
rarely played ok thanks for watching